here's a question for you pap really for
the audience for anybody did the CIA get
it wrong on Iraq and weapons of mass
destruction but more importantly why
does it matter today well it matters
today because as mentioned last week and
at this point I'm hearing it so much
that we really have to go over in more
detail Donald Trump and many of his
supporters have been dismissing the CIA
report about Russian hacking and the
interference in the American election to
help Donald Trump by saying wait a
second David you're trusting the CIA
this is the same CIA that got it way
wrong on Iraq and weapons of mass
destruction and the trumpets have loved
this after Trump said it in response to
the Russian hacking news you saw it
parotid all over the internet and all of
those trumpets recesses of the Internet
unfortunately it doesn't stand up to
even the most minor scrutiny it is not
what the CIA ever said it is a totally
false and incorrect narrative there was
a document from the intelligence
community a 93 page document used to
justify the invasion of Iraq by the Bush
administration now here is every time I
do this I have to speak almost like I'm
talking to a fourth grader which is the
way Donald Trump normally speaks in
order to not be misunderstood the Bush
administration said that this document
confirmed with no uncertainty that Iraq
was actively pursuing nuclear weapons
that they were concealing chemical
weapons they were concealing biological
weapons that they were an immediate
threat to American national security
that's what the Bush administration said
the CIA document said however last year
we were finally able to see how
definitive that document was in its
assertions and it became very clear that
the Bush administration made a lot of it
up to call it an exaggeration would be a
major understatement this is a report
issued by the government funded by the
Finke tank RAND Corporation and it is
called blinders blunders and Wars and it
said that the NIE quote contains several
qualifiers that were dropped
as the draft went up the intelligence
chain-of-command the conclusions were
treated increasingly definitively so the
document the CIA released was very
carefully worded it was very
conservative and here's one example of
how the Bush administration basically
bastardized this the actual intelligence
from the CIA said for example the
intelligence community concluded that
Iraq quote probably has renovated a
vaccine production plant to manufacture
biological weapons but we are unable to
determine whether biological weapons
agent research has resumed how does that
get translated into pro war propaganda
well then President George W Bush shows
up in Cincinnati Ohio on October 7th of
2002 and he says quote Iraq possesses
and produces chemical and biological
weapons and the evidence indicates that
Iraq is reconstituting its nuclear
weapons program document never said that
people are blaming the CIA and the
document you should be blaming Bush and
Cheney and condi rice and : Powell who
misstated the intelligence to make the
case for war yeah it's clear that they
dropped the qualifiers there in order to
cherry-pick the information that they
wanted to sell us a war in Iraq yeah and
unfortunately a lot of the American
people and a lot of people in Congress
just didn't do their homework and went
along with it in September of 2002 then
Secretary of State Secretary of Defense
Donald Rumsfeld said the US had a quote
Babu has quote bulletproof evidence
linking Saddam Hussein's regime to the
terrorist group quote we do have solid
evidence of the presence in Iraq of
al-qaeda members including some that
have been in Baghdad that's not what the
intelligence report said the report said
that it's information about a working
relationship between al-qaeda and Iraq
was based on quote sources of varying
reliability like Iraqi defectors and it
is not clear at all
that Saddam Hussein was even aware of
this supposed relationship there is no
way that you could read
the intelligence report and say it was
the CIA who got it wrong and now the
problem is that trumpets write it all
off because the CIA quote got it wrong
then so clearly they got it wrong about
Russian hacking CIA never got it wrong
about yeah I'll say the analogy just
does not stand up if you want to make an
analogy and this is not an analogy that
the trumpets are going to like the real
analogy to make is we should be
skeptical that the Trump team is correct
because the bush team the Bush
administration ignored data and misused
other data so if the CIA Iraq Bush
administration debacle teaches us
anything it's we should have been
skeptical of what Bush was telling us in
2002 and 2003 and we should be skeptical
of what Trump is telling us now because
in the same way that Bush wanted to miss
state intelligence in order to further
his political goals Donald Trump has a
huge vested interest in miss fading what
it is that we can and cannot believe
from the CIA and the FBI because it
undermines the credibility of his
administration